how about you want to pull up the little
speech he did uh yeah sure yeah yeah
pull up a little speech he did and i
always wanted everyone taking a moment
to appreciate okay we out here talking
about this slap talking about the slap
that was heard around the world
meanwhile ukraine they losing their
homes to big ass bombs and chilling and
they like really y'all [ __ ] talking
about slap i'm looking at clashing cars
and ak-47s russians yeah olgas i know
man igors i got the clip let's talk
about wheel though okay
[Laughter]
i know
to do what we do
you got to be able to take
you got to be able to have people talk
crazy about you
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you got to
pretend like that's
okay i want to apologize to the academy
i want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
um
this is a beautiful moment art imitates
life i look like the crazy father just
like they said
i look like crazy father just like they
said about richard williams
um but love will make you do crazy
things
thank you uh uh hoping academy invites
me back thank you
i want to be a vessel
for love
turn that [ __ ] off turn that [ __ ]
[ __ ] off man i'm so sick of these
kumbaya people turning out to be violent
people in general you know it's always
the ones we'll be like safe space safe
space oh you don't believe in trans
right i hope you die like it's always
the same people you notice that the
kumbaya and the oh i meditate and i'm so
good with myself tend to be the people
who
oh at a break of a time over a single
joke you [ __ ] lose your mind get the
[ __ ] out of here you know what's
fascinating i think it's so interesting
that this man was led up on stage to do
an acceptance speech after he went up
there and blasted a man in his face take
amy schubert put on the same stage make
that joke none of you gonna say you
can't disrespect his wife go ahead slap
the [ __ ] none of you would say that none
of these actors would be coming to will
defense they'd be calling for him to be
jailed
a man gets slapped for telling a joke
all of a sudden it's okay to hit him
that's what it really shows nobody even
talks about it
and we've been saying it on this channel
for a long time i don't even get mad
about it or upset because i'm used to it
no
as it means you already know
if you say something to some people it's
okay for them to slap you apparently
it's okay for them to jump on you
it's such a [ __ ] joke it's
unbelievable this whole thing is a joke
this whole thing is a joke
oh uh the gi jain it's a medical
condition [ __ ] is bald i don't care
stop talking like alopecia is like
terminal cancer or she lost a child or
she lost all her limbs
[ __ ] bowled
you know how many bald [ __ ] i know who
are so deeply insecure about this [ __ ]
they putting on ugly ass toothaches
because nobody want to invest in real
hair for men
they gotta do all this stuff they're so
insecure they're getting hair
transplants they're doing everything
they're using [ __ ] infomercial
products hoping they grow their hair
like chia pets
chicha
chia that's real
we make one joke about her oh but she's
insecure you don't think [ __ ] insecure
about their hair but we've made it
acceptable to make fun of all people our
whole lives
i don't even know how many ball jokes he
has on uncle phil and will smith
in the first place i've been there
i don't even know and trust me stop it
woody slap stop it i thought women can
handle it like dudes can apparently not
apparently not if you make a joke about
a bald woman oh my god
get the [ __ ] out of here bro this is
crazy we literally watch the man get
slapped up on television 4k
and then everybody who's like will's
doing the right thing he's protecting
his girl y'all would have never said
he's protecting his girl if he slapped a
woman like that
yeah but it's a woman you think chris
rock is a big dude
ain't he physically inferior to will
smith i'm pretty somebody who's taking
boxing classes and [ __ ] i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure jada pinkett's making
smack the [ __ ] out of uh
yeah yeah but also the size and the
strength difference doesn't matter does
it
it's just [ __ ] this whole thing is a
bunch of [ __ ] and everyone's on top
of it like oh yes
[ __ ] is bald who cares
well you know what i'll piece on some
woman is probably a blessing she don't
gotta shave her legs all the time
the [ __ ] always come clean
no clencher pops hey she don't even got
no brazilian wax for her butthole
congratulations you ready to get that
booty ate and judging by how freaking
weird y'all he eat that ass
who cares [ __ ] bone bro everybody
eats their ass
no trust me there's a lot of people
don't there's a lot of people watching
right now i was like i don't need ass
i always talk about jada's
facts okay what we learned today is that
you can bang his wife but you can't joke
about her shiny bald head you could ask
for head but don't make fun of her head
[ __ ] what are we talking about
what are we talking about go in
no but but i i
to me it's the hypocrisy of it all that
like i've seen my whole life and i've
seen reinforcing this moment everyone
talk about you gotta defend your wife
you gotta do all this stuff we watched a
man get hit
for something that most of us would
agree is not reasonable and if you just
switch them genders y'all would have had
a whole different ass take
y'all would've had a whole different ass
take and also guys my last point if i
pass it on to you because i've been
ranting oh it's all good live live on
i've been feeling it i i could see that
i've been feeling it oh yeah i see it
because i have people come to try to
tell me on some [ __ ] would he uh
would he have slapped rick driving like
that ricky gervais yeah i don't even
think
there's a cultural thing
where you can slap black men
there's a cultural thing that i know
that i could square up with a
[ __ ] you think so i think so
especially if the [ __ ]
challenges me
oh yeah you want to deal with this [ __ ]
step outside [ __ ] it's kind of part of
our culture it's part of our culture oh
yeah that's how you feel all right and
i've been seeing a lot of things solved
like that
or not i think it would have been more
acceptable if you'd have slapped a white
man because white men
they're not even really human to most
folks
i think it's the opposite do you think
it would have been more like negative
feedback
no no i think what i mean the opposite
is that this is not white men that are
not human right anyways that's besides
the point
um so can you explain that because i'm
pretty sure you want to know because you
said white white men are not human to
some people yeah well to a lot of people
to white people it's it's the opposite
okay and the the reason why the reason
how we've been treated and stuff like
that whatever what not it is what it is
it's an award show yeah they hire a
comedian every year to roast the people
in the crowd you want to show up with
your shiny ass ball ahead and then say
don't joke about it ruff how many times
you've done a set you've seen a ball
woman and you here to talk about it you
can't talk about i've been talking about
everything everything nobody's on the
pedestal nobody has privilege you're all
the same you walk in a room you do
comedy you walk in the room you're we're
all equal you want equality
everybody's equal if you're how would
that person feel i rose that
[ __ ] i rose that [ __ ] i
rose that [ __ ] i jump over the
head of the person that hasn't that's in
the wheelchair and i'll talk about that
i'm singling this [ __ ] out the
people in the wheelchair want you to
joke about them i'm a joke about that
[ __ ] we're gonna act like
[ __ ] bald is worse than [ __ ]
wheelchair stop it i'll i'll joke about
anything if i catch you at my show and
you a bald woman i'd be like hey you
here with your man how long have you
been a lesbian i'm gonna ask questions
oh okay alopecia cool when did you
realize you were into women we gonna
figure it out because i need to know why
we're gonna talk about it the same way
you got no legs we're gonna figure that
[ __ ] out and we're gonna have a laugh
and we're gonna move on but the audacity
of people to go to these events where
you know comedians and they know every
year because there's always comedians
that are being hired and chris rock's
been hired for so long and he's been
roasting people ricky gervais goes to
the [ __ ] academy awards or whatever
it is and roasts everybody
you guys are fine with it emotionally it
happens
i understand i don't i don't know if you
guys are even adults anymore stay the
[ __ ] out of comedy shows if you're so
[ __ ] soft
the con the context is there the context
was how it is presented is comedy
look they did who was hosting three
women there was three women hosting as
well amy schumer went to slacks or
whatever whatever they were doing comedy
was that about was that a comedy a word
no
and you know
listen listen listen people talk about
this unacceptable is [ __ ] baldness
if we can no longer joke about people
being bald because they're insecure then
[ __ ] we can't joke about anything so if
you don't think this is acceptable
reaction you pretty much don't believe
in free speech freedom of speech is not
freedom of consequence but if the
consequences you get assaulted or you
get hit and it's supposed to be
sanctioned because you said some [ __ ]
that someone doesn't like well guess
what we don't have freedom of speech
if people can punch you in your face
because you made a g.i.g and why are we
acting like g.i james a bad joke
gij's a boss [ __ ]
she's the she's the lead actress in a
movie where she handles all the business
am i lying oh yeah actor like she got
roasted to death like somebody brought
up one of her children being done like
stop it dude you know what it is you
know what it is it was not
it was [ __ ] up the thing is it was not
even the gi chain thing it was the you
think it was the build-up it's the
builder i really think it's a build-up
it's not the g.i.j thing it was not a
g.i janjo
in the past two years they've been there
and people been roasting them in the
past years has been that it really has
been there and the thing that happened
is that people that are rich i believe
in the level of will and then the level
of jada uh they get disconnected i said
it we said it before right they get this
so they don't
they just get the backlash and sometimes
they don't understand
how it might sound or look to regular
ass [ __ ]
so
it's
basically
what chris did he put the last drop
that made the pot overflow
but
he's getting all the bad rap because of
the spill that it caused on the floor
but he's not the one that put all that
water in there
he just put the last drop
he's not the one that caused all that
water you know who put all that water in
there
most of that water in there
cheetah and will
but the last drop was too much
i think i think that's what it is we
don't we just reinforce your point go
ahead during the speech what did he say
when you in this industry you gotta take
all them licks you gotta take all this
criticism for everybody and you have to
just accept it so for all the people who
think it's about the medical condition
or the baldness you didn't even listen
to his words right after as he's on
stage crying hysterically looking
terrible will i think just needs to go
to therapy he looks broken i'm not going
french that's just from the outside
looking at could be wrong but he looks
pathetic and he has a pathetic for the
last few years
what did he say
you have to take all these licks so it's
clearly not just about the jokes oh it's
not about the joke so i tried to say
that everybody said you guys are talking
about unrelated stuff if you aren't
paying attention that reaction is not
normal it's not that's a build up it's
not it's not the joke it's not the joke
yep it's the ramification of a whole
bunch of other [ __ ] of the past two to
three years that happened the thing with
august i think with august every
[ __ ] was talking about that [ __ ]
and i don't even think they thought it
would go to that extent
and then they fear finally realized it
would go to that extent they said might
as well capitalize didn't think that
there would be more ramification there
is more ramification and everything
about jada got brought back the
relationship with tupac secured
will smith
august all of them [ __ ] all
that happened and people are bringing
all that [ __ ] back like it was justin
timberlake and sexy and they're just
take it to the bridge
that's what happened
and then you add the little drop that
that's that's that's destroyed i brought
the camera back but and if you think
it's acceptable to hit people for this
reason you don't belong in civilization
i'm just sorry you don't you don't
your feelings got hurt you can go slap
somebody something's wrong with you
mentally
so some of you need to do some maturity
and what we're not saying is this you
have the right to not find a joke funny
yes that's okay yes
you can you can feel hurt about a joke
yes that's fine
yes that's okay
you could be pissed off about a goddamn
joke all day every day
no problem that's fine
but you decide to walk up on the
[ __ ] and like catch them up like
catch them like
and people are celebrating this
i really question folks people have
really like they've really deteriorated
over the last couple decades and think
it's just acceptable to punch people for
a difference of opinion to punch people
because they said some jokes that hurt
your feelings or whatever it's like
you guys have turned into the ultimate
snowflakes it's crazy and you guys want
to sit here and talk about anybody else
or sjws or these [ __ ] you're
sensitive too
it's crazy to me
i i just i i can't believe that folks
are really condoning this openly in
english it's it's kosher and it's a good
thing and it's beautiful that's how
people said this is a beautiful thing we
just saw a black man protecting a black
woman yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here just challenge
him into a fight if you accept and go on
[ __ ] out that's really [ __ ] and
marvel think i'm playing with that [ __ ]
and everything and stuff that's really
solution get your [ __ ] out that [ __ ] is
bold
this is bald
she just bald
she's just bald
listen if we have to like we said if we
have to stop making comedy because it
hurts your feelings
we're not and that's the end of comedy
right there but she's just bald
we got it [ __ ] no no no no no no [ __ ]
she's just bald she's still got her
eyebrows
that's nothing
that's nothing yes but what you get
disconnected that bad
this is this there's a disconnect yo
this nigga's out here with real problems
[ __ ] bald there's a disconnect bro
gas prices i would have fought a [ __ ]
over gas right before i fought [ __ ]
bald
yummy ball [ __ ] at home being like i
wish i had a will to protect me come on
what are we talking about
what are we talking about really say it
come on say
bitch's ball
she is ain't she
which is fine which is fine
amber rose powerful woman wasn't she
yeah but she shaved her own hair she's
not it's not the same thing yeah but i'm
just saying it's like saying oh britney
spears about two that's that's that's no
no we're not doing that hold on hold on
we're not doing this no we're not doing
that hold up hold up hold up hold up
hold up i get that she cut it what i'm
trying to say is that when she cut it
everyone saw it as an empowerment thing
they actually saw it as a positive thing
that she was bald even me before i knew
she had alopecia i thought okay jaina
just doing her thing
when women go bold we see it as an
empowerment thing yeah when men go by we
say oh life hits you hard [ __ ] your
life is over yay how does it feel to be
10 years older
you know what i'm saying i'm just saying
the perception of it is also different
that it's way more positively viewed
yeah am i crazy you got cancer either
you guys
but but at the end of the day it's this
i didn't introduce this all right
you can't be mad at joe walking up to a
[ __ ] hit him up inside the head
no that's not the thing i didn't see one
for dog to kill me someone's like yo
chris rock won't feel that slap yeah the
dog is until august that's great
that's top tier
that should got me going good yeah i'm
gonna feel that imagine if you said it
pow
god damn
she just knock me out i'm going to feel
that in august
if you slap me imagine wake won't do the
hardest
we could have done you're gonna slap me
in not august bruh you're weird like oh
uh okay
okay
will you slap me
in august
i'll be seeing you
is it august i'll see you
is that his day his name's not august
i'll see you well i actually don't know
what's his name athena but close enough
hey i'll see you
i thought i had it i didn't know what to
say i [ __ ] it up no not really you
know what i call that really
you know what i call the call the other
amber girl earlier i was on live i'm
like yeah amber host and i was like
i [ __ ] up all their names